so here's what happens when you give
someone cause right
you look for all the ways to bring that
cause to life and you need
the diversity and inclusion to see
opportunity or see uh breaks that are
gaps because we all have different
perspectives and different upbringings
not better or worse
different yeah different right it's like
it's like even let's just draw the line
on like razor lines like you know
rich people are happier than poor people
are they
you know it's like i know some people
who who came from
meager means who who they understand
they understand teamwork they understand
resilience
they understand loving your mother they
understand gratitude
they understand hard work better than
anybody and they are
good yeah and i know some people who
came from very wealthy means
that that never learned the skills of
adaptability that never learned the
skills of coping
then because everything came easy and
they they struggle through life so
it's it's how you approach it it's not
the circumstances this is viktor
frankl's stuff
if you can't change your circumstances
you change yourself
you know this is viktor frankl 101 we
cannot control the world around us what
we control is our attitude
and so what diversity and inclusion is
all about is about perspective
and so when when when you give people
cause they will look for ways to bring
the cause to life through their
perspective so we have a cause in this
unit in these united states our founding
fathers wrote down for us in the
declaration of independence
all men are created equal this is an
idealized state that we will never get
to
but we will die trying and different
people who have different perspectives
you can see
trying to bring that cause to life the
abolition of slavery
women's suffrage civil rights gay rights
somebody with diverse opinions and
diverse upbringing said hold on
i'm still not included in that and so
you know we start a new effort and all
of those imperfect and ongoing in their
own rights
so when we have a vision when i say
inspired safe and fulfilled
i only have my own perspective and i
have unconscious bias
and i have blinders but if i have lots
of people on my team
we all have our own unconscious biases
and we all have our own blinders but
together we have a broad view
yeah and i need people from
different religions different races
different sexuality different
different job experiences i need people
who have experience in something we've
done before
and i love hiring people who have no
idea about this job because they'll
bring a new
perspective yeah i love putting people
in jobs they
they don't know how to do just like i'd
like taking people who
who are different from than me and
saying how would you solve this problem
and that's the thing we forget which is
you said it's a program based on numbers
and based on color or sexuality
it's it's it's none of those things it's
about perspectives
and different people have different
perspectives and different upbringings
and different perspectives and
all the you know
infinite number of perspectives that
exist in the world because of all the
combinations and permutations
and the best companies are diverse
because they have diverse thinking right
diverse
ideas we make jokes constantly about
you know boards or companies that are
made up of old white men
why because there's one perspective
that's the joke the joke is it's one
perspective
yeah and so the counter to that is if
it's
not just old white men but it's a
diverse group of people
with diverse experiences
magic happens if there's a shared set of
values and a shared vision
without the shared values and the shared
vision then all of that diversity
will subdivide into their little tribes
and they'll go and eat at the lunch
tables all completely separately
and then you need your diversity and
inclusion program because you never
understood it in the first place